et pour en parler nous sommes avec david
rigoulet roze chercheur associé à
l'hélice bonsoir david rigoulet roze
merci d'être avec nous de 900 hommes qui
parle donc d'un accord historique est ce
que vous partagez cet adjectif
d'historique
oui il ya des éléments de langage de la
part de donald trump s'est pas
surprenant parce que donald trump
considère que c'était un objectif
recherché durant toute son
administration c'est à dire de favoriser
un rapprochement avéré officiel entre
israël et les pétromonarchies en
l'occurrence dont les émirats en premier
lieu ce qui est fait et de ce point de
vue là effectivement c'est la stratégie
américaine aussi d'isolement l'iran qui
est mise en oeuvre dans à travers ce
rapprochement
donc le président de l'as roma le vase
présenté comme un succès personnel
notamment dans le cadre de la
perspective des élections de novembre
prochain
par rapport à son noyau dur électoral
l'électorat ou jeu évangélistes
justement très pro israélien et donc ça
rentre aussi dans une logique de
politique intérieure mais au-delà de ça
il ya incontestablement un changement de
paradigme au niveau régional qui aura
des conséquences importantes à moyen et
long terme alors quelles conséquences
justement c'est on peut on peut signaler
que rappeler que c'est le troisième les
émirats puis barennes dernièrement sont
les troisième et quatrième pays arabe à
avoir signé un accord de reconnaissance
et d'une normalisation avec l'état
hébreu
alors que tu as dit en arabe donc sept
ans réalisation a été un tabou pendant
longtemps puisque la normalisation était
conditionnée justement par la
reconnaissance des droits palestiniens
et se trouve qu'aujourd'hui les enjeux
les enjeux régionaux sont très largement
supérieur aux stricts intérêts
palestiniens
en l'occurrence ça justifie des
convergences objective entre israël et
les pétromonarchies par rapport à la
menace iranienne qui est perçu comme une
menace majeure et donc de ce point de
vue là effectivement c'est un tournant
parce que les pays les deux pays qui
viennent de faire cette normalisation
des pays qui avaient été en guerre comme
comme l'egypte qui a signé un accord de
paix en 79 puis plus tard justement les
la jordan et en 94
là il se trouve que ce sont des pays pas
directement frontaliers et donc que
c'est c'est une brèche dans le boycott
abou qatada justement de d'israël par
rapport à ce qui avait été la ligne
notamment de la ligue arabe
enfin des pays arabes dans leur ensemble
pendant très longtemps donc si on
comprend bien la question palestinienne
n'est plus un obstacle à la
normalisation des relations d'israël
avec le monde arabe
cela prouve ça en tout cas en tout cas
il ya eu incontestablement il
d'évaluation stratégique de la cause
palestinienne en tant que tel par
rapport à des enjeux qui qui qui était
jugée supérieure y compris d'ailleurs
parlé les défenseurs de cette cause
palestinienne pendant plusieurs
décennies
parce que là là effectivement
l'obsession de la menace iranienne joue
très très largement dans les
rapprochements en question il ya une
logique sécuritaire stratégique régional
pas uniquement d'ailleurs également
économiques et commerciales mais en tout
cas le la variable stratégique est
déterminant dans ce type de
rapprochement mais on sait que les
relations se sont toujours faites plus
ou moins discrètement maintenant il y
aura peut-être moins d'être d'hypocrisie
est ce qu'on n'est pas plus dans le
symbole c'est pas un symbole parce
qu'effectivement c'est pas le la
normalisation des que ce soit des
émirats aux bars n était plus ou moins
attendu ses terres s'est pas
fondamentalement une surprise il y avait
des contacts depuis plusieurs mois sinon
plusieurs années avec israël des
contacts non officiels on peut rappeler
qu'en 2018 y avait deux ministres
israéliens qui avaient fait le voyage
justement abou dhabi pour justement
d'aider des cérémonies officielles de
type sportives notamment et est donc
cessé ses contacts sous son ancien
simplement là il se trouve qu'il ya une
officialisation qui qui proulx qui a
vers le changement de paradigme au
niveau régional et qui sera avec des qui
aura des conséquences importantes alors
le vrai le vrai la vraie question c'est
l'arabie saoudite parce qu'en réalité
c'est le prince
est-ce qu'ils qui souhaiteraient aussi
pouvoir faire ce rapprochement de
manière officielle mais là il ya dans
lequel l'arabie saudite il ya quand même
un certain de blocage qui pèse et
notamment il ya eu historiquement on va
dire le le plan abdallah 2002 qui fait
que l'arabie saoudite n'est pas dans la
tout à fait dans la situation des autres
pays
elle est obligée de faire preuve de
davantage de prudence par rapport aux
effectives ment à ce type de
normalisation merci beaucoup david
rigoulet roze je rappelle comme cette
chercheur associé à l'iris spécialiste
du moyen-orient merci d'avoir été avec
nous